okay so this is the original Cheerios to
sketch this was done when I was a junior
in high school it was just me a few
friends messing around and stuff and I
wrote this gadget that was kind of funny
and there's no budget we didn't have any
editing equipment so it's all done all
ended it in the camera the sound effects
are just made by me the gun is obviously
a toy gun so I mean it's all very lame
and very silly but at the same time it
is interesting because the writing is
almost identical it's almost exactly the
same one there are big differences
you'll notice is that I am NOT in it I
think I provide the sound effects and
that's about it so that's about it just
watch it and enjoy hey you over here do
you like your breakfast cereal huh
well how would you feel if we took it
away and hey we made Cheerios twice as
cheery rific give me back my damn cereal
but we've added more whole grain the OT
goodness bro your only goodness give me
back my Cheerios but we've created
Cheerios - I don't care what cereal but
wouldn't you like to know that it is 12
times the amount of fiber I don't care
and it has 40 times the amount of
monosaturated carbohydrates I don't
think you don't care but it can even
reduce cholesterol
Cheerios ever since I was a little kid I
was raised on them I need them every
morning for every day of my life please
please give it back but wouldn't you
like to know that Cheerios to has 50
times the amount of vitamins a b c g
through z iron the thiamine riboflavin
niacin folic acid phosphorus magnesium
zinc copper lime nickel Mint platinum
gold silver and trisodium Guba mated
peroxide dominate mono primates number
61 my serious oh I think you've
underestimated by powers oh so you want
to fight the invisible man behind the
camera huh let's get some well I am
right behind you Cheerios may also its
part about our diet
I got your soluble fiber right there
yeah yeah three grams of it daily from
brain old foods honey I like that give
me your o2 thickness Cheerios to toasted
whole grain oat No Who am I kidding we
just put a two on the box it's really
just the same yeah poor fella
geez Cheerios to the cereal with a punch